today we're checking out the shocks open
fit headphones and this is an all brand
new design and I cannot wait to show it
to you a huge thank you to shocks for
partnering with me on this video so you
might be wondering why is this box so
massive for a small pair of headphones
well this is actually a PR box inside
I'm not sure what's in here so let's
open it up
okay this is a huge cut down version of
one of the headphones look at this what
okay this is like the whole this is the
size of my face look at that and here
they are oh we've got a nice little note
12 years ago shocks entered the
headphone space with a mission of making
people's lives better with Innovative
technology look at this so the unique
thing about this is these are not in-ear
headphones they sit like above your ear
kind of like over top of it but not
inside of it wow okay I'm hyped to try
these out let's take a look at this
breakdown
this is like a little art project so
it's got these little slides right here
on the top this is so unique I've never
seen an unboxing like this this is a
breakdown of all of the things that make
up the open fit shocks headphones look
at this this is really cool I'm obsessed
with this I feel like this is an art
piece and this is going to be
prominently displayed in my office from
here on out now I also have the beige
version and this is the consumer
packaging so I'm so excited to open
these up if you guys are interested in
getting more information you can check
out shocks.com for a 45 day risk-free
trial there's free shipping and free
returns in the US and Canada look at
this
oh yeah the beige look awesome oh
they're so soft I feel like a little
like a little pet
also got a USBC cable and you know what
these don't come with extra ear tips
because there aren't any so you just
hook it around your ear and then like it
goes in your ear but like not in your
ear it just kind of sits on top of it
oh my God my audiobook already started
playing all right let me listen to some
music
if it doesn't feel like it's in my ears
it feels like it's like
it feels like it's happening inside of
my head
[Music]
I don't even know what to say because
it's such a shocking experience because
I don't feel like anything's in my I
don't feel them it's just like the music
is coming out of nowhere it's just like
where are you coming from I don't know
why because I don't feel it it's what
I'm so confused my brain cannot
comprehend what's happening right now
[Music]
these open fit shocks headphones are an
open ear Concept in a compact earbud
design now having these built around
your ear leaves the inside of your ear
open to keep you engaged with the world
they are made of a dual layer liquid
silicone that gives you a really soft
comfortable fit that basically molds
itself to all ear shapes these are also
super light weighing just 8.3 grams
these are so great for running because
when I'm running normally I have noise
canceling headphones on and it blocks
out all of the sound so being able to
run with these and actually hear car
horns people it's so much safer and
they're so extremely comfortable like
they're not going to fall out because
they're clipped onto my ears these are
my new running headphones for sure the
audio is also surprisingly powerful with
direct pitch technology made for open
fit it allows for a premium audio
quality that perfectly balances bold
highs clear mids and bass it uses a
proprietary low frequency enhancement
algorithm to carry low frequency
vibrations directly towards your ear
without covering it dynamic range
control dynamically adjusts the EQ in
real time providing a rich and natural
listening experience under any volume
you'll get up to 28 hours of listening 7
hours on a single full charge and the
case will extend it all the way up to 28
hours all of the controls are on the
buds built-in touch pads that can be
customized through the shocks app these
are ip54 water resistant with a double
layer waterproof steel mesh and Gauze
for additional protection these are
super easy and fast to connect just open
and Connect using Bluetooth 5.2 now
what's cool about these is because they
do have that open fit design it won't
take you out of your element so I'm here
in my living room I might have a knock
at the door or I have some food
delivered I'll actually be able to hear
it and if there's people here hanging
out I won't feel like I'm shutting them
out now these have an interesting design
because there's no buttons or anything
on them so to get them to pair into
Bluetooth mode you'll just gently press
down on the tops of the headphones for a
few seconds and then you go into the
Bluetooth settings of your desired
device and then you click these and you
will be instantly paired these are so
comfortable and I think that's what's so
great about these is I don't feel like
something is inside of my ear and you
don't have that kind of nagging feeling
of just oops I just ran off the road
um let me pause my game these have such
a unique feel because a lot of
headphones go inside of your ears they
have different ear tips they kind of
just
May irritate your ears after wearing
them for hours these I feel like you
could wear all day because it kind of
feels like if I was wearing sunglasses
it's just like a slight little pressure
right above your ear it's really hard to
explain but it's so wild because the
sound is so good it's like it's it's
coming from inside of my brain if that
makes any sense the other thing that I
kind of want to test
is a nap test let me let me lay down
let's see what this is like if I lay
down
oh oh this makes me so happy because
anytime you have in-ear headphones
especially on a plane they get jammed
inside of your ear hole
oh this is so great
[Music]
you can catch me taking a siesta on that
next flight
did you connect them yet isn't it cool I
know I was like oh shoot the sound's
coming from my phone right
it's in your head it's so unreal it's
guys I just I wish that I could am I
explaining it okay I don't even know
it's just such a surreal experience
thank you guys so much for watching I
look forward to seeing what you guys
think of these again they are available
in the black and beige if you want to
get more information I'll put a link in
the description and if you haven't
already please like and comment and be
sure to subscribe and hit the Bell to be
notified when I post new videos I'll see
you guys in the next one bye